now there is a vehicle fire that is
completely shut down i-11 now here in
town the freeways are in pretty good
shape it is starting to get crowded on
the 95 515 northbound into the spaghetti
bowl but uh almost two hours ago almost
three hours ago now
look like an rv maybe a fifth wheel
anyway emergency crews are still on
scene we got a little bit of predawn's
early night the truck traffic backing up
across the hoover dam bridge into
arizona but it's also closed the other
way you cannot get from boulder city to
the hoover dam into arizona this is what
caught fire we do have video of this
vehicle fully in flames on our eight
news now twitter account as well as my
personal twitter account as well oh we
also have our own photographer chad
graves down there as well let's get a
look at his view
he says he's about a half mile away and
there you can get a better idea of the
location of this vehicle fire we don't
have any word on injuries we don't know
exactly how this vehicle caught fire and
for travelers maybe the most important
question we do not know when that road
is going to reopen back to the traffic
computer again the roads here in town
are in much better shape and we met